make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are continuing our discussion
on Secret Wars we are picking up with
part five so the conclusion comes
tomorrow which is actually kind of cool
here's a funny thing I was looking
through the comments to the last video
and people were like Spider Man doesn't
become venom in this thing he's just
wearing the venom Sabean we're just kind
of interesting my thought process is if
the symbiote bonds itself to spider-man
and then leave spider-man and bonds
itself to Eddie Brock and starts calling
itself in them it was always venom so
spider-man became venom I guess at that
point you really just kind of arguing
for the sake of arguing but nonetheless
it's interesting right this is one of
those those funny little things it
seemed like people were splitting hairs
in the comments and I was like it's all
the same thing so in the last video we
basically ended off with Galactus
finally activating his world consuming
machine right and beginning the process
of basically starting to like consume
the world and this is one of the crazy
things because the hero's lives
literally rest on the shoulders of their
ability to defeat Galactus here and one
of the funny things this is one of the
things we've talked about so far is that
Galactus has kind of been gearing up to
do this for a while and that's one of
the things to bear in mind when it comes
to Galactus preparing to consume a world
in Marvel Comics is it doesn't happen
like that right it takes time like it
takes a while for him to start gathering
his energies and to basically start you
know consolidating all of this machinery
and then activating the machinery and
then kind of going at it now the funny
thing about this and we'll talk about
that here in a minute is that Galactus
doesn't really need the machinery per se
but it does help because of that when
the various heroes start trying to slow
down Galactus and start facing off
against him one of the things he does is
he kind of starts he sends out what they
refer to as a flyswatter right now this
is just one of the many devices he has
on his a world ship that basically
allows him to deal with various foes now
at the end of the day this is one of the
things to understand here at the end of
the day Galactus is just keeping them at
bay that's really all it is right it's
just kind of a way to just sort of keep
them to keep them busy with something
else while he's able to do his own thing
the truth of this is that if Galactus
wanted to he would just kill everybody
here right he would just wave his hand
and just like disperse their atoms
across the cosmos or do any number of
things to just kill all the heroes who
were here the biggest question to ask
here is why hasn't Galactus done that
yet and we'll actually find out what it
is here in a little bit because that's
kind of the on running question that a
lot of the guys have been asking in the
comments and it is one that does get
answered here but for the most part a
lot of people are kind of musing this
situation are really sort of analyzing
and looking at the situation right the
x-men are the first ones to really
answer the call and jump into the
conflict again if you guys recall
Captain America's forces travel to the
to the base of dr. doom and the the
x-men traveled to the to the village
where they're basically keeping an eye
on Galactus so with the ship activating
this is the fly-swatting device is
basically destroyed but when that
happens it sets off this massive atomic
explosion right this huge amount of
energy is dispersed in a very very small
window and ultimately it creates this
this nuclear explosion that seems to
kill all of the x-men and so when that
goes down the Avengers of course or I
guess really are superheroes but the
Avengers for lack of a better word all
basically end up responding and jumping
into the fray but while they're on their
way there the Incredible Hulk various
other other people are really sort of
analyzed in a conflict are about to get
into right because they're going to
fight Galactus and this is not a small
thing
right like going to find a person who
could just destroy you with a wave of
his hand really begs the question what's
even the point what's even the point of
the various superheroes facing off
against Galactus there's no way they
could possibly win but at the end of the
day they are superheroes and their job
is to try to both keep themselves alive
and protect innocence in this instance
the various people in the village but
really more to keep themselves alive
than anything else and so it was one of
these these these funny kind of
questions because once the vary of
superheroes get there along with Reed
Richards suddenly Galactus teleports the
the world destroying device away and
takes Reed Richards with him and when
this happens you get something that you
don't really get very often and this is
one of the reasons why if you go and you
read like Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic
Four there's a lot of conversation that
goes on between Galactus and Reed
Richards when you go when you read some
of the stories even outside Jonathan
Hickman's run well it deals with the
Galactus and it deals with Reed you see
them talking to each other in a way that
nobody else does right now Reed does
understand the nature of respect being
brought to the ship of Galactus and
being permitted to speak to the lactis
himself that's something that Reed kind
of takes very humbly right so he
basically says I'm honored to be
acknowledged by Galactus and it's one of
these things were it's like you could
just destroy us but you're taking time
from killing us basically to have a
conversation with me thanks bro that's
really kind of when it comes down to but
he asks would you like to view your home
and Reed says yes and then Galactus says
here you go and he shows them what's
going on in his home with Susan storm
who's basically pregnant with malaria
Richard since a reason why she's not
here right now why she hooked took her
place
you've got Franklin Richards there
here's what your family's doing at the
moment and then in turn Galactus says
listen to what it is that I have to tell
you because what I'm about to tell you
is exceedingly important and then we
switch
and then we jump to dr. doom he
basically breaks out of his facility and
dr. doom comes to the realization that
the world ship of Galactus is the key to
it all and in order to access the world
ship of watches in order to do what it
is it he needs to do he ends up taking
ulysses klaw now if you recall we talked
about in one of the previous videos
ulysses klaw after he had been absorbed
by Dazzler and then dispersed onto the
ship of Galactus
he was basically sound resonating
through the ship itself right so he
knows a ship inside and out but that's
not what's important here what's
important here is that ulysses klaw
resonates at the frequency of that ship
right so for those guys who are really
familiar with DC Comics who are familiar
with the flash and the flash like
vibrates you know from from one one
universe to the next if the the main DC
Universe is in the key of a right let
going with musical musical notes if it's
in the key of a and then like earth two
is in the key of C then the flash needs
to vibrate at the key of C in order to
access that universe that's the only way
he can get in ulysses klaw is the exact
same way for all intents and purposes
he's basically Galactus a ship in human
form or at least one portion of it and
so what it means is that by having
ulysses klaw here in effect dr. doom has
a portion of Galactus ship here and
that's what he's just realized right
that's the conclusion that he just came
to and that's why it's kind of important
because from there what you start
getting into is Reed basically showing
back up and talking to everybody and
basically saying that as far as Galactus
is concerned that Reed is kind of this
this you know universal champion of life
right that he's a force of nature just
like Galactus is now something to
understand here is that it's not as
though Reed has been imbued with the
power cosmic or become a herald of
Galactus or anything along those lines
but this is important and the reason for
this comes in really two major events
the first one is the original original
Galactus trilogy when he first showed up
and while we're comics writing the idea
was that read are really The Watcher
with with Johnny Storm and Reed had
basically you know managed to attain the
the ultimate nullifier and and was
really threatening to like destroy
Galactus right so it was like I'm going
unwilling to destroy a universal
constant right a force of the universe
in order to protect life the next thing
that came after that was the trial of
Reed Richards and the trial of Reed
Richards actually came out about five
months before secret war started it came
out in January of 1984 it was secret
Wars coming out now starting in May so
with the trial of Reed Richards it
established the idea that Reed was
actually put on trial by the universe by
various races for the fact that he
essentially saved it save the life of
galosh
and doomed untold billions of people to
death with Galactus going through and
consuming their worlds but the
responsive read is he has to exist right
he has to exist in that capacity
he's a universal force so not only did
Reed do what he needed to in order to
save the earth
but Reed's also an explorer of the
universe right he explores the universe
and even the multiverse various other
dimensions different things along those
lines right transcending the existing
universe going to dimensions going to
the negative zone different things along
those lines
and so with that being the case Galactus
sees him as an individual who really is
kind of the precipice of what humanity
can achieve that in time all of humanity
will be on on the level of Reed Richards
in the sense that they're explorers they
get out there and they look at things
across the cosmos and they're champions
of life this is a pretty significant
moment for Reed but at the end of the
day and it's one of these these
interesting scenarios at the end of the
day read basically sanctions the attack
on Galactus and the reason for that is
because Regis wants to get home really I
mean that's literally what he says you
know when the question is asked like
what about Galactus you know I thought
that you weren't certain about the idea
of attacking him at least that's what
Captain America asks and you know
basically Reed says like I just really
want to get home and so Galactus
initially starts to turn the conflict
and looks directly at the superheroes
and with the intention of kind of facing
off against them but it's one of these
funny things because when this whole
conflict is going on
initially the heroes start attacking the
world destroying machine of Galactus but
the response of Reed is no do not attack
that find some way to subdue Galactus
and where the questions asked why now
forced Galactus takes off and read
responses because he doesn't need the
machine to do this what's going to
happen here is Galactus is gonna go back
to his ship Galactus is gonna consume
his ship essentially consume all the
energy within his ship and then when
that happens he's gonna come to battle
world he's gonna consume this world
we're not gonna be able to stop him he's
probably gonna consume the Sun and then
he's probably gonna go face off against
the Beyonder so all you guys have done
is hasten how fast we're going to die
that's all you've really done here and
that's what makes it a mix is so crazy
because from that point you jump
directly over to you a Doctor Doom and
what Doctor Doom has been doing was is
literally cutting claw into pieces which
is kind of messed up when you think
about it but it's kind of the big moment
because when that happens what we end up
finding out is that what Doctor Doom has
been doing when Galactus goes to consume
his ship he goes to consume the entirety
of his world ship that what Doctor Doom
was doing by realizing that essentially
ulysses klaw was an extension of
Galactus ship that if Galactus ship
holds all that energy that's where it
gets stored whenever he can
things then instead what dr. doom has
done is he's basically split ulysses
klaw into parts and turned it into a
kind of siphon a series of siphoning
tubes built out of the same thing that
is essentially Galactus to ship and when
that happens he basically siphons the
power cosmic off instead of Galactus so
what is up happening is that link a lot
two starts the process of consuming his
world ship instead of the energy
traveling directly into him all the
energy literally flies across the world
and then travels into dr. doom and dr.
doom takes all the power of Galactus now
the funny thing about this is that when
that happens Monica Rambeau as Captain
Marvel is basically sent over there to
investigate and the reason for this is
because no one could really see or no
one could really watch everything go
down given the bright lights the vast
amount of energy different things like
that but Roenick Monica Rambeau is
really like a pure light being right we
saw that both in terms of this story as
well as what was established in Al
Ewing's Ultimates and so with that being
the case he can essentially watch all
this go down well what it does is it
allows Xavier to create a telepathic
link between Monica Rambeau
and Reed Richards so Reed can basically
see through her eyes without physically
having to worry about his eyes being
damaged and what we end up getting here
and this is a cool thing we get Doctor
Doom experiencing the power cosmic for
the very first time now for those of you
guys who read Infinity Gauntlet and who
read the instance where the collector
had the reality stone but didn't realize
the full potential of its power when
Thanos took it and then used it to start
warping reality around collector the
collector started to lose his mod
because he couldn't really comprehend
how reality was being altered beyond his
understanding and that's what's going on
here with Doctor Doom the Doctor Doom is
experiencing the cosmic of the power
cosmic in ways that he's never
experienced before he's never had this
kind of power and that matters because
this is like spending your life drying
of driving a vehicle that has like 108
horsepower right like some Mini Cooper
or something like that you smashed the
the gas pedal and
that's it but then suddenly you get
behind it like a challenger hellcat you
tap that gas pedal and it's like you
just go flying it's a whole new level of
power that dooms never experienced right
so his subconscious can really manifest
all these crazy things the smallest
thought I wish everyone would die they
would all basically die he has to
control his thoughts and his own mind in
a way that he's never had to before lest
the power cosmic basically drive him
insane and destroy everything in
existence right so it's a-- it's a crazy
level of power now this is him
experiencing this and almost kind of
going awry but dr. doom also has an
exceedingly high level of intelligence
and that's what allows him to basically
overcome the insanity that almost
anybody else would endure by taking the
power of Galactus and then using it for
their own ends and so what you end up
getting is the Avengers in the x-men
basically rallying together magneto
using his powers and one of the coolest
moments to basically lift their ship up
and then fly it but then you also get
this really cool argument between
Captain America and and Wolverine and
this is one of the things we've talked
about before right and this is where the
seeds of events like Avengers vs. x-men
get planted and come to fruition you
know some 40 years later or something
like that because what goes on is that
magneto using his power almost kind of
unsettled Captain America insofar as the
grandiose nature of how his powers can
be used right the fact that magneto can
do this and he's not really breaking a
sweat now in terms of a kind of
discussion of why it unsettles Captain
America is magneto sort of says is it
because of my powers because I'm just so
ridiculously powerful is it because I'm
a mutant that you're on that you're not
at ease what's the reason behind this
and Captain America's response is
because of all the evil schemes that
you've committed over the course of your
life and then immediately Wolverine
jumps in and Wolverine says but here's
the thing man like here's the thing
Captain America what's going on here is
you're talking about a guy that yes is
committed some pretty heinous acts but
they were terrible acts with a noble
purpose at the end of the day when it
comes to us as mutants we cannot count
on you like we cannot count on you
Captain America like you stand for truth
and you stand for justice and you stand
for liberty and all that kind of cool
stuff but it only applies to humans when
was the last time you ever came to the
side of the x-men when the Friends of
humanity or the right or any one of
those groups were coming after us when
was the last time that you that you
showed up on our doorstep when humans
wanted to kill us and he wanted to give
us a helping hand that's never happened
you've never really come to the aid of
the x-men you fight for freedom in the
world but you only fight for the side of
humanity you don't fight for mutants you
don't fight for anybody else as
before you start going out and calling
this neo Kali magneto some kind of a
crazy terrorist maybe you should look at
the bigger picture now of course
Captain America responds by saying well
there really is no justification for
terrorism and murder and this is a
really cool really cool response
Wolverine says terrorist that's what the
big Army's called a little Army's that's
really what it is right the big Army's
called a little Army's terrorists you
know but at the end of the day it really
all just depends on what you're fighting
for right it depends on what your cause
is that's the difference between a
person who does terrible things and a
person who does great things is all just
based on your motivations and sometimes
the ends really do justify the means
right but it's kind of a funny thing
because in response to this Doctor Doom
basically looking at everything that's
going on you know kind of jumping back
to his character looking at everything
that's going on kind of has this
discussion with ulysses klaw and
initially ulysses klaw is like you
already have so much power anyway with
the power cosmic
why aren't you satisfied with where
you're at and the response of doom is I
cannot rest if I know that I'm only ever
second best and that right there
perfectly signifies the nature of Doctor
Doom the Doctor Doom always looks to
acquire absolute power
it's insatiable right that was one of
the big points of Hickman's Fantastic
Four is that when they were going up
going around the the multiverse and they
were grabbing every version of Doctor
Doom that tried to acquire absolute
power and then basically lobotomized it
in more or less and stuck him below the
Citadel you know when Reed Richards of
the main Marvel Universe asked why are
you doing this the response of the
council of reeds is because the desire
for power for Doctor Doom is
unquenchable he will never have enough
he'll never be satisfied it's just kind
of the nature of his characters is how
he functions and so in response to this
dr. doom does the only thing he can do
he immediately goes after the beyond it
like literally goes and faces the guy
head-on and he gets kind of nuts because
from that point going forward Reed
Richards basically uses a tractor beam
to grab the body of Galactus and bring
him back down the battle world while
everybody's kind of dealing with the
aftershock so there's what seems to be
this massive battle that's going on
between between dr. doom and the
Beyonder and the crazy thing about this
is this is really just kind of the
beyonders using his power to just sort
of blast dr. doom right to almost push
him away it's not really the the beyond
are using the full totality of its power
to just destroy him it's just kind of
trying to push him away right because
one of the things that says is stop you
cannot approach me right and the crazy
thing about this is that with Doctor
Doom he's overwhelmed immediately it's
it's it's nuts how vast the power of the
Beyonder is in comparison to like the
power of
galactus in the sense that dr. doom bit
off way more that he could chew you know
despite all this crazy power that he has
that previously belonged to Galactus he
is still no match seemingly to overcome
the power of the Beyonder and that's
what's nuts about that because what he
does is he kind of launches this gambit
and he basically approaches the
superheroes in this kind of energy form
of himself and says look I'm trying to
destroy the Beyonder so we can save
ourselves and then I will basically
grant power to individuals who are
looking to achieve a noble purpose
basically espousing the same thing the
beyond or did but putting off this guise
of like I'm trying to save us all so
that none of us died now the truth of
the Avengers and the Fantastic Four in
looking at this is they immediately know
that he's full of crap
they immediately know that the whole
goal of Doctor Doom is to take to
beyonders power but what he does is he
reaches out to the various superheroes
and says lend me your power
lend me your abilities and then in turn
I will channel them I will use them and
then I'll destroy the Beyonder the day
will be saved and I'll give you guys
whatever power you need to achieve your
own individual goals now Magne know
initially starts to bargain like a
initially like right off the bat goes
and runs to Doctor Doom but then stops
himself all of a sudden but before
anybody realizes that he stopped himself
you've got Iron Man and Hawkeye to jump
in and they're just like nah man subdue
this guy man like get this guy down you
know now of course without being the
case Doctor Doom basically just sort of
leaves you know and he's back there
facing off against the Beyonder and it
is almost completely and totally
obliterated right he's not dead but he's
almost completely and totally
obliterated and so what the Beyonder
does is it becomes curious and this is
an important thing the Beyonder gets
curious about Doctor Doom and so it
basically takes his body and starts
scanning its memories right starts
looking through his mind and gets the
entire history of Doctor Doom and his
entire origin right everything that led
up to like the death of his mother
ultimately selling are sold on the Fisto
and then you get everything that you
basically see in Doctor Doom Doctor
Strange triumphant torment or maybe it's
the other way around in terms of the
title but essentially like it starts to
pull his armor off it starts to analyze
his body it basically kind of died sex
him in and out not in a physical sense
right it doesn't really chop them up or
anything like that but it starts to sort
of look at him and say what's this guy
about and so before we find out what
actually happens what ends up going on
is suddenly there's this massive kind of
earthquake and then once all the heroes
are basically able to get out of the
buildings right just kind of run for
their lives the various villains flee as
well and suddenly there's a massive
light in the sky and when they look up
essentially Doctor Doom is like this
colossal
who's like hundreds of feet tall as tall
as tall as Galactus was and that
immediately shrinks down to a smaller
version and says let there be peace here
understand I'm not here to fight you
guys right
I've killed the Beyonder I stole his
power there is no more enemy anymore
everything is copasetic and everything
is fine this conflict is done this is it
I am now absolutely God without being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come as
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you